[Musica]
la mia stella di stasera pur parlando
del presente del futuro prossimo deve
partire dal passato ci sono due storici
francesi che negli anni ottanta dello
scorso secolo hanno identificato un
nuovo modo di raccontare di analizzare
la storia loro non erano interessati
alla storia dei grandi eventi delle
battaglie dei regnanti delle leggi erano
interessati la storia di tutti i giorni
dei desideri delle persone delle loro
curiosità nelle lettere d'amore delle
liste della spesa
questo mi ha ricordato qualcosa non so
se vuoi fa venire in mente la stessa
cosa che a me però oggi sui social
network vediamo quello che forse
cercavano arie dubbi nella vita del
medioevo
ci sono un sacco di persone che vogliono
condividere un sacco di informazioni
sulle loro su su piccoli elementi della
loro storia personale io non sono un
paranoico dei social network non penso
che stiano peggiorando il modo in cui
interagiamo con le altre persone
penso forse che c'è una generazione di
ragazzi che ha conosciuto e pensa che
internet sia un grande sito due tre
grandi siti e non sia invece una
sterminata e meravigliosa città da
percorrere questo concetto peraltro è
stato definito da alcuni quello dei
giardini chiusi dei world dei world
games la mia talk mira ad analizzare il
modo in cui il web 2.0 ha cambiato in un
certo senso il modo in cui percepiamo la
nostra identità online sta cambiando la
nostra percezione della proprietà e
anche sotto il suo aspetto quanto questo
approccio non sia necessariamente
scalabile alcuni di voi si ricorderanno
che nell'aprile 2012 facebook con prog
instagram per più di un miliardo di
dollari
in quei giorni un'altra azienda
famosissima legata al mondo della
fotografia kodak chiudevo a chiudere i
battenti all'epoca instagram a 19
dipendenti cosa che va a più di 140 mila
a persone che lavoravano il rapporto di
me cliente nei confronti di kodak è
molto semplice io compro date una
pellicola su cui imprimerà un mio
ricordo una foto cui io tengo
particolarmente quella foto rimarranno
nei confronti di instagram un pochino
più malizioso il rapporto perché io
ricevo da te un dispositivo una modalità
gratuita per scattare una foto che sarà
di tua proprietà e lo faccio
gratuitamente perché il prodotto sono io
questo è bene a tenerlo a mente più è
sentito un interessantissima
presentazione sul machine learning sulle
intelligenze artificiali
facebook però possiamo sostituire
facebook con google e con altri colossi
del web stanno costruendo oggi
dell'intelligenza artificiale in grado
di analizzare il miliardo e 700mila
persone iscritte a questo social network
per capirci meglio quello che mi
dispiace che tutta questa analisi questa
potenza computazionale viene utilizzata
per profilarsi da un punto di vista
commerciale
secondo lei sarebbe molto interessante
sfruttare queste informazioni e renderle
utilizzabili da noi stessi per
conoscerci meglio
non è detto che il mio psicologo di noi
stessi non debba essere un intelligenza
artificiale
se internet fosse una città il modo in
cui è cresciuto il web negli ultimi anni
farebbe sì che grandi stazioni della
metropolitana nella foto vale mie spalle
ho grandi piazze sarebbero questi
grandissimi siti web che eventualmente
tengono buona parte del web sui loro sui
loro server
questo concetto è promosso e diretto dal
concetto di cloud di nuvola ma io credo
che tutti noi abbiamo sentito in tutte
le salse utilizzare questa parola e
cloud che evoca un'immagine molto molto
bella vediamo questa immagine leggera
molto grande che che sta sopra di noi
veglia su di noi la realtà dei fatti è
che i cloud in realtà sono dei tubi che
passano sotto terra sotto il mare
tutti molto grandi tubi che sono molto
vulnerabili tra l'altro da un punto di
vista squisitamente
per come sono in rosso sono messi sotto
terra che nella piccola scorsa
dell'unica può interrompere o influire
sulle comunicazioni e ci permettono di
mettere in comunicazione un computer con
un altro con un altro computer computer
è molto più grandi
avrete capito anche voi quello che sto
per dirvi e cioè che
non esiste il cloud esiste un computer
di qualcun altro questo è uno speaker
che ho trovato online molto simpatico
che ho visto sul suo computer di un mio
amico
ritengo che sia profondamente vero
profondamente vero questo tutto tutto
funziona perfettamente non saremo noi a
cambiare il modo in cui google facebook
hanno già nei colossi del web hanno
strutturato servizi che appunto
incontrano centinaia di milioni se non
addirittura nel caso di facebook
miliardi di persone
tutto fin quando non si arriva nel
discorso della casa perché adesso chissà
magari alcuni di voi ce l'hanno già
cioè la crescita un boom vedremo
riportare un boom di elettrodomestici
dispositivi legati al mondo domestico
che usano il termine domotica ma non
sempre anche anche in vari altri ambiti
della casa permetteranno di ottimizzare
una serie di processi e quindi
immaginiamoci nella nostra mente un
amazon produttore di frigoriferi per
esempio che ci regala il frigorifero a
patto che però la spesa ce la faccia lui
e magari lo conosce quello che voglio
che voglio mangiare oggi perché è stato
condiviso dai condiviso l'altro giorno
su facebook oppure in qualche altro
social network e vedi di non mangiarne
troppo perché la tua bilancia connessa
mi ha detto che lo scorso week end al
ristorante cinese hai mangiato un po
troppo quindi stiamo entrando in un
mondo in cui questi prodotti non saranno
molto saranno prodotti ma saranno anche
servizi servizi che possono essere
dismessi da un giorno all'altro alle mie
spalle avete una foto di un hub domotico
si chiama rivol
le aziende ragazzi che hanno inventato
rivolgo hanno avuto la fortuna di essere
comprati un certo punto da google
in uno di questi sprazzi di di acquisto
di di start up e google
la prima cosa che ha fatto visto che era
questo prodotto da competitor con un
altro prodotto di google è stato è stato
dismesso e quindi tutti gli utenti che
hanno comprato questo prodotto si sono
visti staccare un servizio ma loro non
aveva comprato i suoi favola del
prodotto
quindi c'è un pochino cioè da chiarire
questo questo rapporto che però
purtroppo mi verdirame non avviene
soltanto nella casa
la piccola segmento di popolazione che
in america ha comprato una domotico
perché mi credo che in questa stanza
nessuna violando gotica in casa io
comunque non ce l'ho questo sta
avvenendo nel mondo dell'agricoltura
ci sono trattori che si spengono se gli
agricoltori non hanno pagato la rata del
mutuo
oggi nel 2016 di in europa e lo sta
avvenendo anche questo non ancora in
europa però sta venendo anche nel mondo
delle auto quindi lo stesso discorso dei
trattori può funzionare anche nel mondo
automotive
questo è un ambito in cui lavoro io io
lavoro nell'ambito degli oggetti
connessi all'intera le cose per lo più
oggetti auto costruiti e questa è una
fonte sisca una un'analisi che ha fatto
un colosso del web che diceva questa è
un'informazione che anche nel 2011
diceva che nel nel 2020 avremo più o
meno 878 dispositivi connessi addosso
ok quello che ha rettificato nel 2015
era che probabilmente l'infrastruttura
web per come è stato costruito il web
fino adesso non riuscirà a gestirli 78
dispositivi connessi per un totale di 50
miliardi di dispositivi connessi tra
case fabbriche e noi che camminiamo
andiamo in giro
corriamo abbiamo il braccialetto che
dice quanti passi abbiamo fatto e quindi
in questo white paper del 2015 che
volevo portare qui volevo portare la
vostra attenzione
cisco ha utilizzato per la prima volta
un termine che mi ha colpito molto il
fog computing of being quindi in
contrapposizione alla nuvola al cloud
cioè questo concetto della nebbia della
nebbia che è locale bassa
io te ci parliamo ma da fuori non ci
vedono io e te ci vediamo quando fuori
non ci vedono l'idea è quella di
contenere a livello computazionale a
livello di potenza di calcolo mantenere
in locale io mi immagino sempre un
discorsi una casa o di una fabbrica o di
una fattoria tutta una serie di servizi
che contribuiscono a al bene collettivo
in un'ottica locale senza la necessità
che la app che ti permette di accendere
la luce faccio una chiamata un server a
san francisco server e ripassa al dato
sott'acqua che arriva a casa mia si
accende si accende la luce
ovviamente non era grazie a cisco ma in
generale un sacco di persone hanno
sviluppato negli ultimi anni
prodotti dispositivi che vanno in questa
direzione per esempio questa
applicazione che è stata utilizzata in
diverse in diversi eventi catastrofici e
viene utilizzata in diverse
manifestazioni permette la comunicazione
le chat ed in assenza di internet nel
mio piccolo in italia
noi abbiamo proposto insieme ad arduino
un progetto di casa domotica che
rispetta questo tipo di concetto di
privacy di analisi e gestione di quello
che possono fare questi dispositivi il
progetto il progetto casa disamina e
livello di agricoltura abbiamo fatto in
quest'ultimo anno degli interventi con
gli agricoltori per andare a disegnare
anche questo discorso traslare questo
discorso dalla casa a una fattoria che è
connessa di in maniera locale quindi vi
lascio con un pensiero positivo non
paranoico a quello che internet oggi e
vi consiglio di fare molto spesso dei
backup
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]